[Music]
ladies and gentlemen you are looking at
your aw world champion Maxwell Jacob
Freeman and it's the one and only Adam
Co babay and we're about to play Truth
or dab because we're better than you
[Music]
baby hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and
welcome back to to another exciting
episode of Truth or dab the hot one
special where we give our guests two
simple options tell the truth or suffer
the Wrath of the last dab and today I'm
very excited to Welcome All Elite
wrestling's Adam Cole and Maxwell Jacob
fredman together they make up the tag
team better than you baby but on August
27th they'll be facing off on the aew
world championship in front of 880,000
fans at Wembley Stadium we're very
excited for that Adam mjf welcome to the
show yes thank you for having us I wish
I was happy to be here but I'm very
excited to be here very I don't like
spicy food he loves spicy food we'll see
how this goes well let me break it down
before we get started in front of you
you guys have a plate of scorching not
chicken wings that have all been doused
in various versions of the last app I
have a set of deeply personal
potentially awkward questions for each
of you and when I ask you a question you
have a choice answer it honestly or
escape the truth by eating a death wing
and Adam we're going to start with you
you know I know that toughness is forged
early in a wrestler's career can you
pull back the curtain on the most
intense wrestling initiation you ever
recall taking part in behind the scenes
oh absolutely uh so when I first started
training I trained uh with a company
called combat zone wrestling in South
Philadelphia it was known notoriously as
being this ultraviolent promotion so I'm
talking fire thumbtacks light tubes the
worst of the worst and my first day at
wrestling school I was still a senior in
high school by the way I was duct taped
to a turnbuckle with my shirt off and
about 30 grown men chopped me not only
until my chest bled but until it turned
purple uh so that was quite the
initiation the the next day was
Thanksgiving so I had to hide that from
my parents to let them know yeah yeah
wrestling went great wrestling went
great so that was a pretty tough welcome
to the pro wrestling industry moment for
me there are people out there that would
pay for that
experience just being honest all right
Max on to you you know the backstage
drama in wrestling can sometimes to me
be just as compelling as what you see
inside of the Ring Gund to head who's
the biggest locker room [__] in aew
today oh
boy oh boy you might want to eat a wing
huh I don't want to eat a wing you might
want to eat a wing you suck all
right I'll eat a freaking there we go
there we go that's a tough one cuz
there's there's people that I like
viscerally hate to my core and to just
point out one would be like physically
mentally emotionally spiritually
impossible I hate everyone accept him so
like what am I can I if I say everyone I
feel like that's a cop a to Max you're a
man of the of high honor I can see I'm
known for how honest I am that's
actually exactly what I'm known for so
I'm going to do this and uh yeah [__]
you guys I'm so watch
this I have an
in wow I don't like that at
all this that's painful you're doing
great oh there's there's more when worse
as you chew it builds a little bit as we
go here
okay what's fun about this you know
nothing I get it I get it I think it the
fun part is people watching this at home
fun part it's f for me it's fun for you
at least so far Adam in in a nice way is
this how like pores experience Joy like
this is the
move did you guys get this from a truck
stop who made this there's a guy named
smoking Ed and and I think he's smoking
meth is what he's smoking this is this
is is brutal all right I guess I'm just
going to tell the truth the rest of the
way well that's a perfect segue here to
this next round because Max we're going
to stick with you you know when we had
Stone Cold Steve Austin on the show he
confirmed this story about him [__]
his pants during a match with Yokozuna
in South Africa reflecting back on your
own career what's the most disgusting or
stomach turning experience that you've
ever I've shot myself in here we go tell
us the story guy's name was Ace Romero
so what happened was
he was coming off the top rope brother
hit me with a splash and like I thought
I took a big enough log before the match
clearly I didn't finish the job luckily
I was wearing black trunks so nobody
noticed and it was a multi-man match so
uh when he landed on me immediately [__]
[__] myself and within that moment I was
like oh you know what I'm just going to
roll out so I rolled out you know kind
of stayed low for a little bit waited
for my moment to strike still won the
match with a full diaper wow uh which is
more than most people be able to say
that's why I'm a world champion didn't
happen by accident you know that's a
banner that they need to hang in the
raft I'd say so yeah so it still hurts I
know and that's swing still hurts I know
Max it's almost a show I have to
apologize for I know I never in a
million years thought you were going to
eat the first wi I didn't want to but
like what am I just supposed to [__] on
literally everyone on the roster one by
one you did the right thing I appreciate
that and that's why we're boys you look
tough right now do I really you I
freaking feel tough yeah all right
all right Adam ewco and GM Tony Connie
wears a lot of hats including head of
creative what stands out is the worst
idea or storyline here's team has
pitched you in your experience I'm going
to dive in to uh
this that's
tremendous I love everything Tony Khan's
pitched to me by the way great guy great
guy how we feeling
mhm angry in my my mouth yeah mhm yeah
got very angry Little Bees oh it is
getting worse mhm I feel like beow abub
is just living in my [__] mouth and I
only ate one H this is good though I'm
training to be a chili Beast this is
very important for me in my growth as a
chili Beast oh my God that this is like
the culinary version of being duct taped
yeah you know yeah not to my chest but
to my mouth exactly I just wish there
was more foreplay that's my issue with
this whole right you know round one
coming right out of the gate very steep
ramp up but the good news is round to
round number three we are halfway
through this whole thing okay all right
Max are going to move to you I'm sorry
he said half real [__] huh all
right all right Max on to you you know I
caught your Infamous rant on Dynamite
last year amazing rant and you put
wrestling fans in the crosshairs calling
them uneducated marks and pretend to
watch New Japan what stands out is the
most most insufferable kind of wrestling
fan to meet in the wild let's go so the
ones that wait at the airport for your
autog for photo about this and I know
damn well half of you chubby worthless
pores aren't even going to go to the
show cuz a you can't afford it and B
you're scum so what they do is they just
hide out and they think they're slick
they'll be like oh mjf can I just real
quick can you sign all 70 of these cards
with your like now
absolutely not so I'm going to say those
are the absolute worst those and
wrestling fans that genuinely think they
understand the how hard and how
difficult it is ah right this Sport and
yes I'm using the word sport you okay
he's not okay is so incredibly painful
and the things that we put our bodies
through is absolutely insane so yeah if
if you're a fan and you're waiting at
the airport and you think you're getting
an autograph from me [__] think twice
[__] it's not happening all right
Adam on to you when we had Undertaker on
the show he told us that he used to
serve as a a judge of sorts in the
locker room who would settle beefs
between wrestlers over the course of the
tour what stands out to you as being the
cardinal sin in wrestling the biggest
cardinal sin in wrestling and then do
you have a story about it being violated
um absolutely in multiple capacities uh
lack of respect is one of the biggest
things and and a lot of it is just
common courtesy things like making sure
that you go around and say hello to
everybody being respectful of people
later on the card being respectful of
veterans things that would see
yeah uh watching the show showing that
you're invested and that pro wrestling
is your life I think that is the the
biggest thing as far as avoiding that
that uh locker room meeting or those uh
judge moments for piggy backing off of
that you're just better off being a
scumbag 24/7 that way the bar is low or
you could do you could do I love them
but we don't agree all the time we don't
agree all the time all right on to the
final round oh shoot okay Adam we're
going to go to you first okay event pay
can be a hot button issue in wrestling
what stands out is the biggest Main
Event payday you've ever gotten and then
what do you expect to receive it all
in all
right great question though great
question
though you're a chili Beast Adam you're
a chili Beast you can do this you were
born for this you're prepared for this
you watch this show this is everything
you've ever dreamed of everything you've
ever wanted are you okay leave me alone
Maxim in the zone let the Beast off the
chain let the chili Beast off the
chain I'm uncomfortable I'm
uncomfortable oh my god
dude had to go all in
it to go all in get your tickets now
also you can buy pay-per-view oh okay
definitely not on fire on the topic
you've been very vocal about the
impending bidding war of 2024 you know
the deal on what date does your contract
expire and then what's that price tag
going to need to be to keep January 1
2024 they better back up the goddamn
brake truck okay pal uh realistically I
uh I know that there's a lot of money
that's going to be thrown my way from
both sides I'm not accepting anything
under 7 I I won't even I won't even make
eye contact with a contract that's under
f telling the truth here on Truth or dab
August 27th these guys at Wembley
Stadium for all the marbles make sure
you check it out Adam Max anything you
want to say to the fans before we put
you into an ice bath you call yourself
chili Beast there's two more left on are
you kidding me right now I'm just
bringing this up I'm casually bringing
this up if you want me to eat These
Wings okay there's not a chance in hell
I'm doing it unless you eat yours not a
chance [__] okay not I'll tell you
what I like blue cheese can I put Blue
chees on the wi yeah we are in Uncharted
Territory right here you know we are
past the credits there are no rules here
okay tell you what I got three you got
two I think it's a little unfair to
layer three on all the way that's cuz
you're a Pansy it's not my fault you
know
want damn okay I'm just going to do a
bite though you know
just don't fight
him
incredible those are horrible cheers yep
good oh Max you love to see it oh my
[__] god oh no oh it's
building and still going back in all the
way to the Finish Line a sight to behold
finger
licking let's make some noise yeah yeah
[Applause]
August 27th be there be square be a part
of history and you're going to want to
be a part of History because we're
better than you
baby
[__] I'm [__] dying right now you
know what it could be kind of cool if
it's like a like a sports press
conference if you're holding the belt
and we're [__] oh yeah
yeah thumbnail [__]
there it
[Laughter]
is you're breathing heavy Sean are
you eyes are still watery yeah oh I'm
[__] dying right
now hot ones fans it's been years in the
making but at long last the next big
thing in Wings is finally here
introducing hot ones buffalo sauce our
spin on Buffalo is a rich and tangy
combo of cayenne peppers distilled
vinegar and and yes real butter which
means that you can put hot ones buffalo
sauce directly on wings no mixing or
melting required it's the best damn
buffalo sauce I've ever had in my life
but don't take my word for it camera guy
Bill Buffalo's favorite song gives it to
Blazing thumbs up don't you Bill that's
a Buffalo Bill
[Music]
guarantee heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands on
the brand new hot one's buffalo
[Music]
sauce